these are a sequence I will stop with
the secrets concern some more basic name
the series you step I write the sequence
is a bit like a set right you know it's
a bunch of numbers I suppose but what
does it have on top on what do they have
in addition to a sir
what's more specific about a sequence a
set has order sorry a set doesn't have
one of the sequence Hezbollah sir adding
order makes a sequence right so we
talked I think in the Fibonacci sequence
and then actually taking the sum of all
of those adding everything up makes it a
series okay so now we're gonna have a
look at a more specific client of
sequence series the first one is forward
are Mexican ones called geometric but
there's our clinics actually look at
under each one so we just cover and then
words today so what's an arithmetic
sequence
and every sequence contains terms that
have a public difference so for instance
we've actually already looked at a few
athletic sequences before Christmas
beyond the sequence or even numbers when
you think about how these work because
how we've defined this sequence right
there's a comma difference between every
right so you can see here we started to
a common difference is to write in the
same way the odd numbers a holster and
any sequence in fact they have the same
difference
starting point right okay so do you
remember the floor we were defining it
in three different ways to actually
specify what makes up a sequence right
the first way you can see on the board
right which is we just named a few terms
a second way was to give you a
definition for each individual term so
we say TMM is equal to something so
let's think about the even numbers if
you've got T 1 B 2 T 2 B 4 and so on how
could we define the even numbers well
every even number every term is just
double whatever term it is right so the
first term is 2
so you can just define it very simply as
to memory now what you'll find is that
every arithmetic sequence it's very
similar in that every term will be n
times a constant right so K times n and
they are also some other clothes that
hang off the saddle it was hella look at
this tree for instance if I were to take
the definition for the editor of an even
the even number sequence where how are
you just this we looked at this before
how would I adjust it to make it the odd
number seeds what would I do
I'm just and then you've got the okay so
what this summary here takes care of his
way you begin and this number B here
takes care of how far do you progress as
you go from turn-to-turn right okay so
for instance it'd be really easy to say
these are the even numbers what's T of n
what's the nth term for saying the
multiples of 3 3 6 9 12 every time
you're going up what constant you'll be
going 3 right so in other words if we
were to find this you know if I said
instead of an N term counting right if I
gave you these - yes you would recognize
that as a linear function right it's
growing at a steady rate that's why it's
a straight line so often you'll see
people refer to arithmetic sequences or
arithmetic series as a kind of linear
function because that's how they growing
right if you plotted them if you put on
all of your terms you'd get
off you go behaves just like a minion
function there you go alright so if the
nth term is going to be some constant
times out of counting tournament right
how do we get the sum of a whole
sequence of such so let's think about if
we're actually calculating once we add
them all up right and let's consider an
example where well we want to consider
sort of finite sequences by that series
for now because it was infinite that
he's gonna be really had hard to add up
right now but not impossible you work
out how to take care of infinite
sequences in series later on but let's
just start with something simple so for
instance let's consider the first bunch
of odd numbers let's go all the way up
to say 99 ok this is a finite sequence
right the first odd numbers for all the
odd numbers really underneath 100 how
would we find this sum of this well you
could just bash it out right you could
actually write out words and get your
calculator out but of course if you ever
been given this task like saying you
know you seven or eight or something
that you can see there's a faster way to
do this isn't there right is this
because of the UM the order the
orderliness of this series and there's a
pattern we can exploit right it'll
become a little obvious if I put a few
more of the N terms over there
so let's see if I'm going to say okay
now here's the idea because the
arithmetic sequence is defined by this
common difference bit right you can see
that if I take for instance um turn one
and turn what would that be
maybe ton 50/50 turn forty nine ten
fifty because we're 2 n minus 1 right so
there's 10 P if I add these two up right
they're going to turn it 200 now as I go
forward one term together
I add two and if I come from here
they're backward I subtract two right so
you can see turn three and turn 49 also
a Maltese and you can keep on doing this
now the question is how many times can I
do it how many of these are hungry to
make them again
and the answer is well because I am to
make a hundred I have to take two of the
terms right
so I'm pairing up everything so how many
pairs of people could you make out of
say 50 people it's up 25 pairs right so
here this son and I guess we're talking
about the first 50 terms right
the sum of the first 50 tails is equal
to in this case we said there are 25
pairs of numbers here at every pair adds
up to 100 that's our son right so just
like we have you know
now we've got some new notation okay now
there's a specific example can we
generalize this how we go about it
although you have a think actually if we
didn't have actual numbers here right
but say let's define the first term
whatever it is let's call the first term
a that's a nice letter that indicates
first this and the common difference
between every number what do you think
would be a nice letter for the common
difference
yes original okay if this is what
defines our sequence and that's all you
need to define it matters instead of 1 3
5 7 and so on right
I would have a what would be the next
term a plus D and then the next one
would be okay now
here we had 50 terms yeah if I had n
turns
this is term one this is turn two
how many months of the common difference
plus turn one hat and has none of them
right so you could write this as a plus
zero D if you like the second term has a
plus I'm not gonna say I'm just going to
write it okay the third term has two
months of D so how many lots of the
color difference will the very last the
M term n minus one watts of the common
difference so can you come up with an
expression for what's the sum of the
whole thing in general terms